تعرف منظمه ليغاد نفسها بانها هيئه حكوميه
دوليه للتنميه ومكافحه الجفاف في منطقه
القرن الافريقي وقد انشات التخفيف منها
اثار الجفاف الشديد المتكرر والكوارث
الطبيعيه الاخرى تاسست ايجار عام
1986 وتتكون من ثمان دول هي جيبوتي
السودان جنوب السودان الصومال كينيا
اوغندا اثيوبيا واريتريا واتفقت هذه الدول
على تعزيز التعاون الاقليمي في الامن
الغذائي والتعاون الاقتصادي والسلام
والامن اضافه الى مجالات غيرها
تمتد دول منظمه على مساحه تبلغ 5 ملايين
و200 الف كيلو متر مربع ويبلغ عدد سكان
دولها اكثر من 230 مليون كما توجد في
منطقه دول الايجارات عمليات دعم سلام
تابعه للامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
ويبلغ عدد جنود هذه العمليات اكثر من
خمسين الف